si vous laissez tomber votre marteau et
une plume en même temps lequel touchera
le sol en premier ne pariez pas la
question est un piège s'il y a des
frottements de l'air oui la plume va
planer plus longtemps mais sur la Lune
sans air les deux tombent à la même
vitesse il n'y a plus de questions de
masse ou de surface seul compte la force
gravitationnelle ça a été testé sur
terre dans une salle sans air et c'est
totalement vrai des phénomènes
contre-intuitifs comme ça il y en a
plein vous allez pouvoir piger vos amis
en leur faisant faire des paris que la
science vous garantit de gagner comment
ouvrir une bouteille de coca secoué sans
la faire exploser on a tous fait cette
blague vous devenez prudent et dégazer
petit à petit mais si je vous disais
qu'on pouvait l'ouvrir d'un coup sexe
sans qu'elle explose il suffit juste de
tapoter légèrement la bouteille comment
ça pourrait faire baisser l'énorme
pression cumulée parce qu'il n'y a pas
de pression c'est une idée reçue elle ne
change absolument pas quand vous secouez
et c'est logique on ne rajoute aucun gaz
à rien il reste à l'équilibre dans la
bouteille autour des trois barres
techniquement vous pouvez la secouer
pendant sans qu'elle ne perde jamais son
pétillant dans ce cas pourquoi j'observe
le contraire pourquoi elle m'expose au
visage les véritables coupables sont les
bulles de gaz du dessus que vous
emprisonnez dans le liquide elles vont
créer des petites poches qui attirent le
dioxyde de carbone on appelle ça des
sites de nucléation vous pouvez voir ces
bulles sur les parois dès que vous
ouvrez la bouteille qu'est-ce qui se
passe la pression diminue les bulles
sont moins comprimés et elles gonflent
ce qui pousse le liquide par en dessous
pour éviter ce problème il vous suffit
de tapoter sur les parois de la
bouteille pour briser les sites de
nucléation les bulles d'air remontent
vers le haut de la bouteille là où elles
étaient à l'origine c'est aussi ce qui
se passe quand vous mettez un manteau
dans une bouteille de coca non ce n'est
pas à cause d'une réaction chimique la
preuve ça marche aussi avec une paille
en papier en fait à la surface du bonbon
ce n'est pas du tout lisse regardez-moi
tous ces micro trous soit des millions
de sites de nucléation potentiels qui au
fond de la bouteille vont tous chercher
à sortir en même temps d'où l'effet de
geyser maintenant si vous enfermez la
bouteille à temps il ne se passera rien
la pression n'augmente pas et les bulles
de gaz ne s'échappent pas une autre
expérience que vous pouvez réaliser chez
vous c'est de naviguer sur Internet avec
cybergot VPN en un clic c'est comme
avoir le pouvoir de téléportation
regardez ce que propose Netflix sous
prime aux États-Unis cyberg VPN est un
billet d'entrée vers tous ces trésors
cachés plus de 40 services de streaming
c'est aussi un allié pour de gros
économies changer facilement votre
emplacement en ligne pour trouver les
abonnements Spotify ou Destiny plus les
moins chers au monde même les
réservations pour vos vacances et je te
parle même pas de la protection de la
vie privée et du contournement des
restrictions gouvernementales un must
have cybergot VPN c'est la confiance de
38 millions d'utilisateurs avec 5
étoiles sur Troyes pilot et un service
client agent 4 vous n'êtes jamais seul
en expérience on a une offre pour vous
83% de réduction 4 mois gratuits
garantie satisfait ou remboursé sous 45
jours 2 euros et 3 centimes par mois
pour sécuriser 7 de vos appareils
faites-en profiter vos amis et votre
famille PC mobile console ou TV
l'univers vous attend embarqué
immédiatement lien en description
comment faire fondre un glaçon plus
lentement que les autres je vous
présente deux verres d'eau l'un
contenant de l'eau pure et l'autre salé
dans chacun j'y ajoute un glaçon lequel
fondera en premier ce serait logique de
penser que le sel va dissoudre le glaçon
plus vite vu qu'on jette du 7 sur les
routes pour faire fondre la neige mais
non en fait le sel ne fait pas fondre
mais diminue le point de fusion de la
glace la température à laquelle on passe
de l'état solide à l'état liquide en
temps normal l'eau pure commence à geler
à partir de zéro degré si vous venez
ajouter des impuretés comme le sel l'eau
n'est plus pur ce qui modifie sa
composition et son point de fusion avec
23,6% de sel l'eau ne gèle plus avant -
23 degrés c'est pour ça que ça fait
fondre la neige et il ne fait plus assez
froid dehors rajouter plus de sel ne
servira à rien on attend ce qu'on
appelle le point eutectique qu'on peut
quand même faire mieux avec 33% de
chlorure de calcium le point eu tactique
passe alors à -56 degrés parfait pour
dégeler en Sibérie ouais enfin ça reste
pas logique pourquoi dans mon verre le
glaçon font plus lentement que dans
l'eau salée ça devrait pas faire baisser
son plan de fusion un autre phénomène
est à l'oeuvre lorsque glaçon fond dans
le premier verre il produit de l'eau à 0
degré qui se diffuse dans tout le verre
ce n'est pas le cas avec le salé
beaucoup plus dense c'est un peu comme
s'il y avait de l'huile l'eau froide et
pure est bloqué ce qui forment un cocon
autour du glaçon qui garde le froid un
autre phénomène est en cause c'est que
verset du sel dans l'eau produit une
réaction chimique qui refroidit elle
vole de l'énergie on l'a dit
endothermique le deuxième d'air est donc
plus froid maintenant que vous avez
gagné votre pari vous pouvez tenter un
deuxième celui de retirer le glaçon d'un
verre sans le toucher avec vos doigts
pour ça il vous suffit de placer une
ficelle sur le glaçon et d'y déposer du
sel au contact le point de fusion de
l'eau diminue le glaçon fond et votre
ficelle se retrouve dans l'eau devenue
localement liquide mais au même moment
le sel se dissout dans l'eau et fait
diminuer la température du mélange c'est
grâce à ces deux phénomènes contre
intuitifs que votre ficelle se retrouve
piégé sous une fine couche de glace il
n'y a plus qu'à soulever comment séparer
l'eau du vin dites à votre ami en soirée
et que vous êtes Jésus et que vous allez
séparer l'eau et la colle de son shooter
tous donc vous avez besoin c'est de sel
encore la boisson que votre ami a dans
son verre est en réalité un composé d'un
mélange d'eau et d'alcool quand vous
achetez une vodka c'est 60 % d'eau ça
fait cher la cristalline maintenant
quand vous ajoutez du sel dans l'eau il
va s'y dissoudre et s'y mélanger
parfaitement c'est beaucoup moins le cas
pour l'alcool l'eau va être alourdie par
le sel sa densité augmente et petit à
petit elle se retrouve au fond et
l'alcool au-dessus certains selles sont
d'ailleurs plus efficaces pour cette
méthode de séparation mais ils ne sont
pas alimentaires comme le sel de route
au final ce n'est pas une méthode de
distillation miracle mais ça peut amuser
la galerie comment faire bouger l'eau du
robinet sans la toucher vous n'aurez
besoin que d'un objet en latex genre un
ballon de baudruche vous ne voyez
toujours pas comment ça va nous aider il
suffit juste de le frotter et de
s'approcher du filet d'eau l'eau est
dédiée sans la toucher c'est grâce au
champ électrostatique lorsque vous
frottez un isolant comme du caoutchouc
avec tissu vous arrachez quelques
électrons de la surface du chiffon et le
caoutchouc se charge négativement les
molécules n'aiment pas ça elles vont
essayer de revenir à un équilibre
électrique en volant les électrons
ailleurs avec l'audio robinet ce sont
les molécules d'eau qui sont attirées
d'un seul côté car elles ne sont pas
électriquement symétriques elles
alignent leur côté chargé positivement
vers le ballon négatif vous pouvez aussi
frotter un objet en plastique et parier
que vous pouvez attirer uniquement les
grains de poivre d'un mélange poivre sel
le champ électrostatique va les attirer
tous les deux mais le poivre est 4 fois
plus léger à partir de là vous pouvez
inventer toute une panoplie et variante
de ce défi faire bouger des copeaux de
papier à distance avec un peigne des
pailles en plastique dans la même idée
vous pouvez faire bouger des céréales
comme par magie tout ce qu'il me faut
c'est un aimant et un bol d'eau de lait
car dans les céréales il y a du fer le
même que dans les épées c'est un élément
indispensable pour notre corps on s'en
sert pour fabriquer l’hémoglobine par
exemple rassurez-vous il y en a pas des
masses 4,3 mg par paquet il en faudrait
250 pour fabriquer trombone c'est pour
ça que vos céréales à sec ne se jettent
pas sur votre aimant les quantités sont
tellement faibles on va devoir utiliser
un liquide pour faciliter le mouvement
du fer l'expérience fonctionne encore
mieux sur les céréales bonus aux
États-Unis par exemple les Kellogg's
complexes à haute Brown 14 fois plus
féreuse attention quand même ça peut
réduire l'efficacité de certains
médicaments comment éteindre une bougie
sans souffler dessus juste en hiver sans
de l'air comment c'est possible quand
vous allumez une bougie pour que la
flamme brûle il lui faut de l'oxygène
l'air que nous respirons en contient 21%
et c'est largement suffisant mélanger du
vinaigre avec du bicarbonate de soude
cette réaction va produire du CO2 pour
qu'il ne s'échappe pas refermer le bol
maintenant il vous suffit de verser ce
gaz sur des bougies ça va étouffer la
combustion et vous verrez les flammes
s'éteindre une à une par manque
d'oxygène c'est le principe des
extincteurs qui libère du CO2 noyez la
flamme un autre pari serait d'éteindre
une bougie en soufflant dessus même s'il
y a une bouteille entre la bougie et
vous à première vue c'est impossible
votre souffle serait bloqué sauf que non
il va en fait longer la paroi un peu
comme de l'eau qui contour un rocher
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet Kunda et
quand vos deux souffles se rejoignent
ils créent une zone de dépression
derrière la bouteille une zone où il y a
moins d'air que l'environnement ce qui
va créer une aspiration un courant d'air
suffisamment fort pour éteindre la
bougie à l'inverse si vous soufflez dans
un entonnoir votre souffle ira le long
des parois finissant éparpiller à la
sortie il vous sera donc impossible
d'éteindre une bougie une version
extrême de ce défi serait de mettre une
balle de ping-pong dans l'entonnoir et
d'essayer de l'expulser avec votre
souffle vous n'y arriverez pas votre
souffle va créer une telle dépression en
passant tout autour de la balle qu'elle
va rester coincée dans l'entonnoir plus
vous soufflez plus la balle sera aspirée
comment défier la gravité ce défi là est
très vicieux je parie que je peux
fabriquer une pente qui fait remonter
les objets au lieu de la descendre il
vous suffit de former un V avec deux
bâtons si vous y faites rouler un simple
cylindre vous verrez rien d'anormal il
descend vers la pointe mais si vous vous
amusez à fabriquer une roue à partir des
deux cônes attachées par leur base la
roue va remonter c'est de la science en
réalité et du point de vue de notre roue
fabriqué si l'on suit son centre de
gravité elle ne fait que descendre tout
le long du trajet pour nous la roue
remonte la pente alors que pour elle
elle ne fait que descendre ce n'était
qu'une illusion si vous avez du mal à
comprendre regardez ce schéma avant et
après qui vous donne l'impression que la
roue remonte la pente avant que vous
fassiez rouler votre roue elle se tient
appuyé au point zéro après vous la
fassiez rouler vous voyez bien que le
double cône a pu au point 1 quand vous
superposez ces deux schémas en
alignant.0 et point 1 vous vous rendez
compte que la roue a bien descendu
malgré la pente qui descend dans l'autre
sens en fait la force spéciale de votre
roue fera qu'elle descendra plus dans le
sens contradictif de la pente en
comprenant mieux les phénomènes
physiques qui nous entourent on arrive à
faire des tricks vraiment sympa vous
avez pu également constater que tout ce
que vous aviez pu prendre pour de la
magie quand vous étiez gamin n'est autre
que simple phénomène contre-intuitif à
retourner le cerveau n'hésitez pas à
tous les tester avec vos amis pour
remporter tous vos paris et nous dire ce
que vous en pensez merci à cyberg VPN
d'être notre partenaire sur cette vidéo
profitez des 83% de réduction
et 4 mois gratuits satisfait remboursé
sous 45 jours et profiter d'Internet
sans limitation le lien en description
merci au rédacteur au monteur et
abonnez-vous si vous souhaitez d'autres
vidéos du genre je vous dis à bientôt
Ciao
[Musique]